[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم سقط قتلى وعشرات الجرحى في
انفجار سياره مفخخه استهدف شارعا تجاريا
في منطقه الرويس في ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه
والتي تعتبر معقلا لحزب الله نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لكي نناقشه في محورين ما هي الرسائل
التي حملها انفجار ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه
المحسوبه على حزب
الله وما هي التداعيات الامنيه والسياسيه
المحتمله لهذا الانفجار على المستويين
اللبناني
والاقليمي لن تتضح بعد الحصيله النهائيه
لضحايا الانفجار الذي هز منطقه الرويس في
ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه مساء الخميس لكن
احصاءات اوليه اشارت الى ان الانفجار الذي
نجم عن سياره مفخخه وفق المعلومات
المتوفره حتى الان اودى بحياه نحو 20 شخصا
واسقط اكثر من 200 جريح بحسب مصادر امنيه
وطبيه في لبنان وياتي انفجار مساء الخميس
بعد نحو شهر من انفجار اخر وقع في الضاحيه
اللبنانيه وسقط من جرائه 50
جريحا موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع ضيفين
من بيروت فيصل عبد الساتر الكاتب والصحفي
المقرب من فريق ثامن من اذار ومع علي
حميده الكاتب الصحفي في جريده النهار
اللبنانيه والمقرب من فريق ال 14ب عشر من
اذار سيد علي حميدي الجميع استنكر ودان
الحادث ودع الى الوحده الوطنيه ولكن
سياسيا على الارض مع مع كل المشاكل
السياسيه في لبنان الى اي حد يمكن لهذه
الدعوات انت القى صد
حاليا لا اكيد تلقى صدا لانه هذا الامر
يجمع عليه اللبنانيون بصرف النظر على
الخلافات السياسيه الخلافات السياسيه في
الداخل اللبناني شيء والتفجير الارهابي
الذي حصل وص
اصاب جزءا عزيزا على قلوبنا في لبنان هو
شيء اخر الدماء اللبنانيه كانت في الضاحيه
الجنوبيه او كانت في بيروت او كانت في
بعلبك او كانت في طرابلس هذه دماء لبنانيه
مستحيل مستحيل ان نتجاوز هذا الامر لنقول
بانه هناك شيء ما لبنانيا قد يبرره او قد
يخفف من وطاه الالم الذي نحس به هذه
الليله مع سقوط اكثر من 20 شهيدا وربما
اكثر
وعشرات الجرحى وتدمير الواسع الذي
حصل خلافنا السياسي قائم كان قائما قبلا
هو قائم اليوم وسوف يبقى الخلاف السياسي
الى ما بعد لكن هذا شيء وا الارهاب شيء
اخر سيد فيصل عبد الساتر كيف نفسر اختراق
هذه المنطقه المحسوبه على حزب
الله اولا دعيني ان اتوجه الى تعزيه لاهل
الشهداء والطلب الى الله سبحانه وتعالى
بان يخفف عن الجرحى والمصابين وان يخفف عن
الناس ما اصابهم هذه الليله من هذا
التفجير الارهابي موضوع الاختراق يعني نحن
نعرف ان الاختراق هو اختراق للامن
اللبناني ليس هناك اختراقا لمنطقه دون
اخرى ليس هناك اختراقا لبيئه دون اخرى ما
اصاب اليوم الضاحيه الجنوبيه هو يصيب
لبنان بمقتل على المستوى الامني كما اصابه
على المستوى السياسي بمقتل منذ زمن بعيد
نتيجه الخلافات الحاده والانقسام السياسي
العميق القول بان المنطقه هي منطقه دويله
داخل الدوله هذا منطق سقط منذ زمن بعيد
لان الحاجز الامني هو حاجز وهمي يتغذى من
ال يعني يتغذى من الحصانه السياسيه اذا لم
يكن هناك في لبنان حصانه سياسيه ولم يكن
هناك وحده سياسيه المسرح يصبح مهيئا لكل
انواع الاختراقات هذه المره في الضاحيه
ربما المره الاخرى في مكان اخر تماما لكن
المحصله هي واحده هي خساره للبنان وخساره
لكل اللبنانيين خصوصا ان الذين استشهدوا
اليوم هم من المدنيين الابرياء بينهم
اطفال ونساء وكل الممتلكات التي تضررت
اليوم هي تعود لمواطنين يعني بالكاد
يحصلون على قوت يومهم اما اذا كانت
الرساله تريد شيئا اخر على المستوى
السياسي هي خلق حاله خوف وترويع لدى
المواطنين او لدى بيئه حاضنه للمقاومه
اعتقد ان الرساله اخطات في عنوانها لاننا
نقول ولا زلنا نقول ان المستفيد الاول
والمستفيد الاخير من هذه الجريمه ليس اي
لبناني ليس اي اي احد في هذه المنطقه سوى
اسرائيل وبالتالي كائنا من كانت الهويه
التي تنفذ هذه الافعال نحن نقول ان الهوء
والهويه اسرائيليه من يريد ان يستهدف
البيئه الحاضنه للمقاومه بما انك اعترفت
انها بيئه حاضنه للمقاومه وهذا كان
المقصود بالسؤال ان تقول استهداف لكل
لبنان هذا صحيح ولكن هذه المنطقه شئت ام
ابيت محسوبه على حزب الله وهنالك نفوذ قوي
له فيها وهنالك من يسميها دويله لكن على
الاقل هنالك نفوذ امني لحزب الله في تلك
المنطقه من يريد ان يستهدف هذه الحاضنه
كما سميتها
للمقاومه النفوذ الامني شيء والنفوذ
السياسي شيء والبيئه الحاضنه شيء
والاستهداف الامني شيء اخر الاستهداف يطال
لبنان برمته لان هذه المنطقه هي جزء من
الدوله اللبنانيه وبالتالي مسؤوليه
الاجهزه اللبنانيه ان تحمي مواطنيها وتحمي
كافه المناطق اللبنانيه مهما اختلفت
التسميات بعض الاحيان مهما ك كان هناك من
تباينات او خصوصيات لمربعات معينه او
لمنطقه جغرافيه على المستوى الامني لكن
هذا لا يسقط من حساباتنا ان الدوله
اللبنانيه هي المسؤوله اولا واخيرا عن
الموضوع الامني اما عل حما سيد علي حمادي
وصلت فكرتك وصلت فكرتك السييد علي
حماده السيد فيصل متاكد من انه
استهداف لكل لبنان هذا صحيح ولكن لا يريد
ان يقول ان هنالك
منطقه محسوبه على الحزب الله هي المستهدفه
هنا في هذا الموضوع هل توافقه
الراي لا طبعا يعني في هذه الليله هذا راي
كل اللبنانيين هذا استهداف لكل لبنان الان
فيما يتعلق بالشان السياسي اذا اردت ان ان
تذهبي ابعد في ال ال في في البحث عن
النقطه السياسيه في
ذلك هناك هناك استهداف حتى الان اولا لم
نتبين تماما ما هي طبيعه هذا الاستهداف لم
نتبين حقيقه من يقف خلف هذا العمل لعمل
الاجرامي انا اؤكد لك باننا بان الخلاف
السياسي كان قائما قبلا وهو قائم اليوم في
هذه اليوم وسوف يبقى لكن ما بين الدم
والسياسه هناك بون شاسع ان ان يذهب
اللبنانيين نحو اللبنانيون نحو الدم فهذا
امر مستحيل ولن يحصل ولا نريد ان يحصل
وطبعا نحن نعتبر بانه كل الخلافات
السياسيه تتوقف عند حدود سلامه المواطن
وامن المواطن وحريه المواطن الان خلافنا
مع حزب الله خلاف كبير وخلاف مزمن وخلاف
ربما ق يدوم سنوات لكن هذا لا لا يمكن ان
ان ان يجعل بانه هذه البيئه ان نقول هذه
البيئه مستهدفه وهناك بيئات اخرى غير
مستهدفه لاننا غ قد نفيق صباحا على
استهداف لبيئه
اخرى تحتضن اطارا سياسيا يناوئ حزب الله
مثلا ماذا سنقول عندها سوف يقول يقول منذ
حوالي 40 يوما في بئر العبد وايضا صاروخ
في البقاع وما نسمعه من هنا وهناك عن
تهديدات بسبب تورط حزب الله وعناصره في
سوريا
الا يقودنا ذلك الى التساؤل عن هذا
الاختراق وعن
دوافعه يا ستنا لنكن واضحين في السياسه
قلنا منذ اشهر ونحن نقول بانه حزب الله
متورد في سوريا وانه حزب الله تورط حزب
الله في سوريا سوف يفتح ابواب جهنم وقل
قلناها وكتبنا في مقالاتنا وفي تصريحاتها
وفي مواقفنا هذا امر لكن لكن هذا هذا لا
يعني وهذا ونحن لا نعرف في هذه الليله
بالتحديد من من هي الجهه الفعليه التي تقف
وراء هذا العمل الاجرامي قلنا ذلك لحن
لكننا نحن لا نبرر هذا الامر ولا يمكن ان
نبرر امرا من من هذا النوع حتى مع مع
خلافنا الكبير مع حزب الله حول تورته في
سوريا نعم حزب الله متورط في سوريا ونحن
ضد هذا التورط ونقول له منذ اشهر انسحب من
سوريا انسحب من سوريا ليس لديك لك اي شان
في الحرب السوريه او في الازمه السوريه عد
الى لبنان وعد الى طاوله الحوار والى
تشكيل حكومه حياديه هذا امر لكن ما حصل
الليله جعلنا يجعلنا جميعا بصرف النظر عن
هذه الخلافات غاده انه نقول انه الان
لحظه تامل اللبنانيون يحتاجون الى التامل
الى التفكير الى
العقلنة انوه بنقطه واحده شعوري وبالرغم
انه ما عندي معلومات شعوري بانه حقيقه
ليست هناك ايد لبنانيه تقف خلف هذا العمل
الاجرامي وهذه نقطه ربما في وسط هذا
الظلام الكبير هذه ربما نقطه نور او او
هيك وميض صغير يعني يمكن ان نبني عليه
لاحقا ليست هنالك ايد لبنانيه ماذا تقصد
ايدي اسرائيليه سوريه
شع يا ستنا انا بعتقد انه هذه انه هذه
ربما قد تكون يعني هناك احتراب اقليمي
هائل هناك هناك صدام اقليمي هائل كلنا
نعرفه ونتابع ونحن حاولنا واردنا منذ
البدايه ان نقول خلينا بلبنان ان نحصن
الواقع اللبناني وان نن بانفسنا تماما عن
هذا الاحتراب وان لا ندخل في ميداني هذا
الاحتراب الاقليمي الان اللي حصل
حصل وجهه نظرنا وجهه نظر الاستقلاليين و
وقوى 14 اذار واضحه علينا ان نبحث مع حزب
الله لاحقا فوق الالم فوق الدماء ان نعبر
الى البحث جديا في في ما كل ما يمكن ان
يجمع اللبنانيين ويحمي هذا الوطن الصغير
اللي لا نريد عرقنه لبنان مع مع محبتي
واحترامي للعراق وللعراقيين لكن نحن لا
نستطيع ان ان نعيد هذه الحاله التي عشناها
مده 17 عاما حيث كانت السيارات المفخخه
تجوب لبنان من اقصاه الى اقصاه لا نستطيع
ولا نريد ولن نقبل وسنعمل يدا واحده نبقي
على خلافاتنا ونبقى مختلفين لكن الخلاف
السياسي
والخلاف المواقف شيء اما الدم فشيء اخر
سيد فيصل عبد الساتر هل من الصدفه انه
عندما تورط حزب الله في سوريا بدات
التهديدات تكثر عليه
واخترقت الضاحيه الجنوبيه اكثر من
مره
يعني هو ليس من قبيل الصدفه كما انه ليس
من قبيل اليقين يعني لماذا نربط هذه
القضيه حتما يعني بشكل
يعني يعني بشكل اكيد بما تتفضل به ربما
هذا يكون جزء لكن اذا كنا نتحدث عن تورط
حزب الله الذي يعني البعض يعني ممكن ان
يتخذه ذريعه طيب لماذا تدخلت كل الدول
وتورطت فيما يجري في سوريا ولا يجري فيها
شيء قطر الم تتورط السعوديه الم تتورط
الشيشان الم تتور المانيا فرنسا بلجيكا
وولايات المتحده الامريكيه كلهم تورطوا
هذا هذا الحديث وجهه للذي للذي انفجر
واعترض يعني اذا كان المفجر معترض على
تورد هذا تساله له انا اسالك يعني من وجهه
نظر حزب الله هل هل تعيد النظر هل تعيد
النظر بما فعلته في سوريا بسياستها في
سوريا على ضوء انها اصبحت مهدده في الداخل
اللبناني وتهدد لبنان
كله او اسمحي لي يعني يعني ان يكون هناك
متسع من الوقت ل لكي اكمل الفكره انا قلت
اذا كان منطق هؤلاء التبريري لكي يفعلوا
في لبنان وان يستهدفوا لبنان على خلفيه
تورط حزب الله يعني تورط جه جهه خارجيه
غير سوريا في الازمه السوريه الا يعطيهم
نفس التبرير او نفس المنطق بان ايضا
يفعلوا نفس الشيء مع دول اعلنت بشكل واضح
انها تورطت في سوريا اذا كنا نبرر لهذه
الجهه هنا
هذا الامر فل نبرر ايضا يعني من جهه
اخرى سي يعني لا تقولني ما لم اسالك ا
مثلا مثلا مثلا انا اقول مثلا انا اعطي
مثال الا يحق لي ان اضرب الامثله انت
تقولين ان السؤال يقول ربطا بالتورط لحزب
الله في سوريا هذا يعني ايضا ان اخرين
ممكن ان يبرروا لانفسهم ان يضربوا عمق قطر
والسعوديه والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وباك د
سيصل هذه الدول حتى ول تابعنا منط هذه
الدول ليست هشه كلبنان يعني انت تعتبر
الان لبنان دوله قويه فيها امن وفيها
استقرار انت تعرف الوضع وبالتالي لبنان
الحلقه الاضعف وهو وهو ما يقوله يعني
الخصوم الذين يعارضون تورط حزب الله ان
دعونا نن بانفسنا لان لبنان لا
يتحمل اولا يعني خلينا نكون اكثر وضوحا
بهذا الامر يعني عن اي تتحدثين انها دول
يعني مصر دوله الان تونس دوله ليبيا دوله
اليمن دوله الصومال دحيد عن الموضوع
التشبيه ليس في محل سيد فيصل ارجو يعني
عندما يرسل حزب الله عناصر الى سوريا
لتشارك في القتال هذا غير مواقف اخرى تدعم
يعني موقف السعوديه وغيرها يدعم المعارضه
بشكل واضح لا يرسل افرادا منه تحارب هنالك
هذا كان المقصود بالسؤال على اي حال سيد
علي حمده يعني بشكل سريع لو سمح ابدا لم ا
اذا سمحت اولا يعني يجب ان يكون هناك
توازي وتساوي وتعادل في الوقت اذا كنت
تريدين جوابا على السؤال فل تعطني الوقت
الكافي اولا هذا غير صحيح هذه الذريعه
المستمره في موضوع تورط حزب الله في سوريا
نحن نعرف ان حزب الله مستهدف من اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ليس على
خلفيه التورط في سوريا بل على خلفيه اشياء
اخرى تماما نحن نعرفها وانت تعرفين وكل
العالم يعرف ان حزب الله استطاع ان يمرغ
انف العدو الاسرائيلي في لبنان وان يهزم
كل هذا الكون الذي تامر عليه في 2006 هذا
الانفجار ياتي في عشيه 2006 وبعد العمليه
التي تبناها حزب الله بالامس على لسان
السيد حسن نصر الله من ان عبوات منطقه
اللبونه في جنوب لبنان انما زرعتها لبونا
نعم انما زرعتها المقاومه واعل لنا انه
سيقطع رجل اي احد من العدو الاسرائيلي
يدخل الى الاراضي اللبنانيه لماذا لا نقول
افتراضا وهذا الافتراض يفيد الساحه
اللبنانيه ولا يزيد في جزمتها الا اذا
نريد ان نذهب الى من تبنى العمليه اليوم
باسم طائفي واضح او باسم مذهبي واضح ليقول
للبنانيين اقتتلوا وارفعوا رايه الاقتتال
المذهبي نحن نرفض الاقتتال المذهبي
والطائفي بل نرفض اي اقتتال داخل
اللبنانيين بل نرف ض اي اقتتال على
المستوى الاقليمي اذا كان عنوانه طائفيا
او مذهبيا نعم هناك صراع سياسي هناك مخطط
سياسي خطير في المنطقه ربما الان بدا ينفذ
في لبنان على خلفيه الاستفاده من بعض يعني
التبريرات التي كما تفضلت بالسؤال ربما
تكون وجيهه للبعض لكنها
غيرين سد علي حمادي اذا كما قال السيد
فيصل عبد الساتر تاتي عشيه ما يسم حزب
الله النصر الالهي في نهايه حرب تموز 2006
وايضا حتى جنبلاط اتهم اسرائيل وايضا دعاى
الى تعاون جهازي الامن اللبناني وحزب الله
جهاز امن حزب الله لحمايه الناس هذه
الاولويه بالنسبه اليه ما
رايك يعني اي ما عناه النائب وليد جملات
هو انه علينا ان نقلع في لبنان داخليا عن
التبادل والتراشق بالاتهامات والتراشق
بالتبريد نعم ليس هناك هذه الليله احد من
اللبنانيين يبرر هذا العمل الاجرامي هذا
عمل اجرامي ارهابي نقطه على السطر اثنين
فيما يتعلق بالوضع الامني ما قصده النائب
ولي جملات اذا انا فهمته مضبوط هو انه
هناك مشكله داخل الاجهزه الامنيه
اللبنانيه انه انها تتنافس فيما بينها
وليس هناك التنسيق الكافي فيما بينها
وفيما يتعلق بالتنسيق مع جهاز امن حزب
الله الامر ليس فقط فقط بالتنسيق الميداني
مع جهاز امن حزب الله الموضوع يتعلق ايضا
بالسياسه يجب ان ان نجلس مع حزب الله
لنبحث
بالمسار المقبل الذي سوف ننتهجه كلنا
جميعا كلبنانيين وكيف يمكن ما هو السبيل
من اجل ان نمنع دخول الاحتراب الاقليمي
الى لبنان بهذا الشكل الدموي ح الده
الوطنيه هناك من يتحمسون من يناصرون
الثوره السوريه من هم ضد الثوره السوريه
هذا امر اخر بالسياسي اللي بدك اما فيما
يتعلق بالدماء اللبنانيه فهذا امر يجب ان
معا لانه الامر خطير اليوم 20 اتيل
بكره 200 اتيل ط تقول تقول ما السبيل
اليست حكومه وحده وطنيه كما يطالب حزب
الله وحلفائه اليست الا تجيب عن سؤالك
فيما انا بتقديري لا لا لا بتقديري لا
لانه وضع حزب الله ال وضع حزب الله
السياسي الخارجي هو وضع سيء للغايه ونحن
ماذا ماذا عرضنا على حزب الله عرضنا على
حزب الله انه نحن نحن الاستقلاليين وقوه
ماني ازار يعني القوى الملتحقه بحزب الله
ان نجلس جانبا ان نقف جانبا وان نشكل
حكومه حياديه من التكنوقراط ومن التقنيين
لكي يرعوا مصالح الناس اليوميه وان نذهب
مباشره الى طاوله حوار وطني برعايه فخامه
رئيس الجمهوريه لن حث في مووضوع
استراتيجيه الدفاع وعمليه استراتيجيه
الدفاع الوطني هي البحث في امره سلاح حزب
الله ومن يسيطر على هذا السلاح ومن له
امره الحرب والسلم في لبنان وطبعا مشروعنا
هو انه لازم ان غير شيئ في المواقف من
تشكيل الحكوم برايك هذا الانفجار لن يغير
شيئا هذا الانفجار لن يغير شيئا الموقف من
تشكيل
الحكومه لا لا لا هي هذا الامر انا قلت لك
لك انه الخلاف السياسي كان قائما قبل وسوف
يبقى لكن ربما ربما هذا الالم الكبير وهذه
الدماء التي التي سالت اليوم هذه الدماء
البريئه التي سالت اليوم انا بتقديري ربما
يجب ان تدفعنا جميعا الى ان ان ان ان نهدئ
اللعبه وان نذهب الى حوار عقلاني والى
البحث في عقلانيه مش بكيديه متبادله وليس
باتهامات متبادله وليس بالتراشق المتبادل
لكي نبحث في امكانيه انقاذ هذا الوطن يعني
نيران الاحتراب الاقليمي وصلت الى لبنان
شكرا لك شكرا جز اليوم اثبتت انها وصلت
الى لبنان كيف ننقذ لبنان يجب ان معا
شكرا جزيلا الكاتب الصحفي علي حميده وايضا
اشكر السيد فيصل عبد الساتر الكاتب
الصحافي واشكركم مشاهدينا الكرام على
متابعه هذه الحلقه بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج من وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا